convierte 37 centímetros 37 centímetros
a metros y déjame escribir esto por aquí
son 37 centímetros y vamos a poner de
diferente color para enfatizar el
prefijo sentí 37 centímetros y vamos a
querer convertir estos centímetros a
metros y bien solo para recordarnos un
poco que significa el prefijo sentí
literalmente significa 1 sobre 100 o es
igual a 1 sobre 100 un centésimo de
metro por lo que es decir 37 sobre 100 o
37 centímetros que es equivalente a
decir que tenemos 37 centésimas entonces
puedes escribirlo como 37 por un
centésimo de metro o bien decir lo que
son los 37
que decimos y bien esto de aquí son los
37 centésimas de un metro lo cual
también lo podemos reescribir con una
notación decimal que sería igual a cero
cero punto y ponemos nuestros 37
centésimos o bien que son puntos 37
metros punto 37 metros y otra manera en
cómo puedes pensar esto es observando
que para pasar de centímetros a metros
vamos a necesitar 100 centímetros para
obtener un metro por lo que entonces
vamos a dividir entre 100 para lograrlo
entonces qué tanto del metro voy a tener
hablando de estos centímetros y en
realidad siempre tenemos que checar que
si convierto centímetros a metros ver
que si voy a obtener un número más
grande o un número más pequeño pero
bueno de cualquier forma los centímetros
que tengamos en metros siempre es una
unidad más grande por lo que entonces
sería lógico que tuviéramos
un valor más pequeño el cual será un
factor de 100 así que ahora con nuestros
37 centímetros que estoy poniendo de
diferente color este par de unidades
observa bien un centímetro es igual a 1
sobre 100 por lo que un decímetro va a
ser igual a 1 sobre 10 entonces esto va
a ser equivalente a tener 3.7 decímetros
observa bien como un decímetro es igual
a un décimo de metro entonces
simplemente dividimos entre 10 y luego
dividimos entre 100 para nuestros metros
por lo tanto tenemos punto 37 metros y
si observas aquí lo que pasó es que
estamos recorriendo nuestro punto
decimal primero lo recorremos una unidad
hacia la izquierda para hablar de los
decímetros y la segunda unidad que
movemos a la izquierda es para hablar de
los metros y listo